WELCOME TO GRAMPY GOOBIE'S
EULOGY VIDEO.
- WE HOPE THAT OTHER PEOPLE
ENJOY THIS
WHEN THEY PLAY IT
WHEN YOU DIE
'CAUSE WE KNOW
YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO SEE IT
'CAUSE YOU'LL BE
IN THE GROUND.
[cheerful music]
EARLY LIFE.
- I AM GRANDPA GOOBIE
AS A YOUNG MAN.
I'M HORNY.
- WARTIME.
- GRAMPY GOOBIE
IS SIGNING UP FOR THE WAR.
WAR II.
HITLER'S ROLLING FOR POLAND.
- OH, NO, IT'S DICK TRACY.
AHH!
- OH, NO.
- BLOOPER REEL.
- WE SHOULDN'T BE
DOING THIS ON-CAMERA.
[bleep] IT,
LET'S JUST DO IT ON-CAMERA.
VERITE.
IF GRANDPA GOOBIE COULD BE
ANY ANIMAL IN THE WORLD,
WHAT ANIMAL WOULD HE BE?
- UM--
- PILLS.
- [laughing]
- REST IN PEACE.
[laughter]
- KILL BILL, BRO.
[screaming]
- CUT MY NECK!
- I FEEL LIKE--LIKE,
"HOUSTON, WE HAVE A PROBLEM,"
AND THE PROBLEM IS
THAT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH LOVE.
THE LACK OF LOVE IS REALLY HARD
FOR ME TO HANDLE RIGHT NOW.
- A BAPTISMAL, WENDALL.
LET'S DO IT!
YEAH!
- THAT MUST HAVE BEEN
HARD TO DO.
- OH, MY GOSH, YEAH.
IT WAS SO--
I'M SO WET.
- I'M SO WET TOO.
- WHAT THE [bleep]
IS GOING ON?
GRANDPA GOOBIE WOULDN'T
WANT THIS THIS WAY.
- GRANDPA GOOBIE IS DEAD!